quiero empezar de cero
ensayan para hacer las próximas Voces
del doblaje en España y Luis querra es
quien los guía por este arte que ha
cambiado mucho en los últimos años desde
la pandemia por ejemplo los guiones
impresos se quedaron obsoletos
preparaba tres guiones por película por
documental y ahora todo lo tenemos Ya
digitalizado no esto es lo que van
trayendo lo que es o sea lo que trae y
lo que conlleva las nuevas tecnologías
en este caso pues bueno pues mucho mejor
una nueva tecnología está poniendo en
alerta a la industria la Inteligencia
artificial Pablo Fernández cofundador de
varias empresas de ia asegura que los
actores no desaparecerán pero sí tendrán
que reinventarse probablemente los el
trabajo de los dobladores a futuro no
será repetir o leer lo que pone en un
texto sino será dar instrucciones a la
Inteligencia artificial de quiero que me
dobles esto sonando como este actor no
Entonces pasas de ser un instrumento a
ser un de Orquesta Raúl se prepara para
reunirse con los directores de doblaje
de videojuegos que forman parte de a
doma sindicato de actores de doblaje de
Madrid que el preside son parte de la
iniciativa y un airet voice arest este
grupo global de sindicatos de actores
pide transparencia en los contenidos
generados por Inteligencia artificial y
una compensación por derechos de autor
el resultado que va a dar va a ser
porque ha cogido la interpretación de
pues x decenas cientos o miles de
actores y actrices las Ha deformado
hasta que ninguno sea reconocible y se
inventa un timbre según los parámetros
que le estén dando es una simulación
hecha con un montón de interpretaciones
que pertenecen a alguien
autores invisibles que temen ser
sustituidos y que levantan la voz y
esperan que las únicas iniciales y a en
la industria del doblaje sean las de
inteligencia artística